we've been offended by his language but
mostly were worried about his thinking
his thinking in relation to trading is
thinking in relation to the economy and
how it works was thinking about taxing
and imposing fury import and this is
something that already happened in
United States a hundred years ago
President Hoover proposed the same
policies to tax imports and to limit the
effort of corporations to go and invest
abroad to keep themselves competitive
and resort depression the mammoth
Depression of 1929 was the result of
those policies Mexico's government paid
too much attention to that and not
enough to some of the issues going on in
its own backyard was going to assure us
that is just rhetoric in Mexico we think
that poor is content that forum is
substance so we better watch out and
worry and especially the American people
that's why I'd been telling them wake up
he's a false prophet his proposing ideas
that will not work but on the contrary
instead of saving jobs they're gonna
lose jobs Mexico we import from United
States seven hundred and fifty thousand
billions of US dollars that means six
percent of all the jobs in the United
States to American citizen so we are
accountable in Mexico for 10 million job
to US citizens so he's not presenting
the things on the right context
certainly there's a lot at stake here
but is it Gia
and a bit of a distraction from again
issues of corruption scandals at home
oh what a studio well we do have
corruptions but as anybody else but
mainly Mexico is derived from the huge
the mammoth drug consumption in the
United States because in Mexico we don't
consume drugs we don't produce drugs we
just happen to be in between the mammoth
consumer market in the north and the
produces in the south and so here we are
with this big big problem and yes those
cartels those cartel lords race here in
the US market 55 billion US dollars a
year which they use to corrupt which
they used to hard get to work for them
which they used to buy weapons and
ammunitions here so the United States
has to decide whether legalizing drugs
or whether implementing a policy to
prevent drug consumption in the state
because we are paying the price and we
don't deserve that certainly that's a
big discussion to have but I wonder is
corruption so endemic to Mexico's state
and local governments and police that
the drug cartels essentially have all
the leverage and call all the shots I
don't think that that's a well described
concept but it's not true we do have a
degrees of corruption not bad I cannot
deny that but in in my government we're
absolutely transparent we created the
best law on information to the public
about anything that goes on with
government it's not the main Mexican
problem the trouble is is war on drugs
that came to be because of the huge
market in the United States